oh boy let's see what we get going on
here
why is everything always a mess I clean
and then it just gets destroyed again
I'm just gonna say it's cuz I'm creative
yeah I got a few interesting packages
that I'm gonna open here today this one
I don't even know where it's from I mean
I know it's from its from YouTube but I
don't know what's in it I'll set you
right here I'm still in my PJs I've been
editing all day today like losing my
mind I need to get out of the house I
gotta go outside which we're gonna do
here shortly so it says it's from
YouTube we created something for you
because you created so much for the
world YouTube you guys are cute I'm
actually running at YouTube shirt this
is not planned I this is what I slept in
Jesus what is it
it's all--it's walk 30 pieces of
original art inspired by real fan
comments dramas will give on the in
comments brought to life through its the
six different artists from around the
world oh my gosh youtube you guys are so
thoughtful it takes a lot of balls to be
who you are and live your life out in
the open and share it with everyone
that's true this is so cute
I'm very insecure and you made me look
at things from a new perspective it's
kind of hard to read something that's
this close
that's about it readings low this is
amazing thank you YouTube thank you you
guys for always leaving such amazing
supportive comments granted there are
comments that aren't supportive and
amazing but you know what that comes
with the territory and I'm going to put
this on my coffee table
it smells like print let's go start our
day even though half this day is already
over I wasted it editing okay let's go I
gotta take you with me oh that's your
high ended up here
I'm meeting Matt Jenna let me get some
lunch do a little shopping for New York
got to do some returns and some jewelry
that I got bring in for our wedding that
she did
like let's see if we can find Jen on
Matt
I found those bones crack where's Matt
he's in the dressing or Matt Oh Matt
show us your goods actually I'm not sure
where which one even what's a good as
Cheesecake Factory we don't want to go
just new always golden we just with the
last time we went not too long ago
okay go here come on guys come on okay
we'll go to the cheesecake back wait cuz
me and Jenna are so sweet it needs it
all the many outweigh the needs of the
few you know what if you really want to
go here Matt let's go to the cheesecake
back oh you should go to antica whatever
it's called yeah but you know what I
know you really want to go to cheese
news night race look well let me just in
the Sun oh I didn't like it
pick pick the pizza place okay I think
Jenna's gonna choose if the majority
rules yeah I know justine just told me i
should pick the pizza called we are not
supposed to tell whispered in my ear
that's not okay
be nice okay coin I have a coin get a
coin I don't have a coin it's 2016 we
could have been eating we could have
been done eating we're downloading a
coin flip app dude if you Google coin
flip there is one like it just it just
shows up so we're gonna do best out of
three yeah best out of three heads
Cheesecake Factory tails
okay good do it that's not a three yep
that's 140 ski go go go this one for
cheesecake gosh this is riveting content
Ailsa yeah oh my god here it is gonna be
tails
really doesn't love pizza do you not
want pizza
no yet you left off well let's look at
the menu and just make sure there's
something you'll eat your I've lost
where the gg back to me let's let the
record show Matt let the record show
please let the record show that I lost
the bet fair and square
I went to do the coin flip I lost I went
into the pizza place and then they still
wanted to come here it actually worked
out well because jello might want to get
breakfast and I'm just gonna get a salad
and I can get that anywhere so yeah
we're doing a great job showing cohesion
as friends
Cheers heading to get a manicure those
pink is disgusting I liked for about two
days and now I want to I want to cut my
fingers off got a little bit of shopping
done I left it out on mat because I was
in a hurry because I still have so much
to edit tonight hopefully I actually
shoot these videos that I plan on
shooting tonight I really really really
really want to they're too fun cooking
videos one is for Mother's Day and the
other one you probably won't see for
like maybe three weeks you guys have any
ideas of some things that you want me to
cook leave me those in the comments or
you can tweet them to me tweeting is
usually a little bit easier because I
like when you guys attach pictures to
the food so that I can use those as
screen shots in the video to be like
look this is great there's a dog with a
he he has three legs
he has three legs and he's wearing a
camo jacket he is my spirit animal whoa
okay it is so windy
and don't like that why would you ever
do something like that
this looks yellow it that's disgusting
well that looks a little better as far
as color goes but it's still dark what's
in the box what could be in the box
what could be his box oh man there's
another box inside the box yeah okay
which side is up I just don't know if I
feel like assembling something right now
do not drop the side up are you
assembled not assembled
think I'll just leave this here till
somebody comes over and feels like
putting it together
I might have to save this for another
day I think I will that was fun
Marc let's see what we've got red blue
maybe let's just stick with this basic
color so I want to pose this video today
I don't know what I did I went shopping
and did some things I'm thinking about
organizing my closet later tonight I'm
not sure if I should
I usually go through and donate a bunch
of things that I don't wear to either
Goodwill or Salvation Army so I think
that's what I'm gonna do so that's gonna
be really fun I thought it would end
this video with a nice little ass I J
okay boy go go hashtag ask IJ seriously
though why don't you have a cooking show
why don't I have a cooking show have you
seen any of the videos that I've posted
on the Internet
that's why where's the ask i J um it's
right here I dare you coming to Orlando
for playlist playlist was this weekend
so unfortunately I did not go I didn't
make it I went to Legoland do you think
that Apple will use us BC on their
iPhones if so when I think they will
probably do it definitely not for the
iPhone 7 potentially for the iPhone 7s
really I'm not sure do you remember when
you reacted to it does the Fox say
is still my favorite video of all time
a little DJ just gene be going on tour
with EJ mini Matt oh yeah YouTube didn't
pay would you upload on a regular basis
yeah actually I probably would I started
making YouTube videos when it wasn't a
job when it was just for fun and I think
that is one of the things that has made
YouTube's still fun for me is I started
it in a place of being a creative outlet
not a place to make money and it's still
for me is that granted yes it is
technically a job Maddie come here I
just heard a sound I'm scared hold on
okay oh my goodness I worry about this
dog so much quite distraught what was I
saying something about YouTube being a
job and fun and I still enjoy it I love
it I don't know honestly I was
reflecting later on after I filmed the
intro of this video I was talking about
how do you guys and the comments and
things like that and it just breaks my
heart
to read hateful comments not only
comments on my videos I mean I'm
somewhat used to it but still no matter
what it still hurts
but to see it on my friends videos and
and even people talking about my friends
in my videos like it come on they just
don't say anything
look if you want to say it so bad
breaking type it in the text or notepad
and then delete it just don't say
anything
you're free to think about whatever you
want or if you feel like you have to say
something text a friend and vent it's
much better that way I promise you what
is the most important item that you
bring with you when you go out with
Maddie definitely his leash trying to
find a trainer to work with him that is
just like I don't know it's really a
struggle I want him to be able to be off
leash but I'm also afraid I don't want
to run away I don't be hit by a car he
is my child okay my firstborn just not
born from my body anyway just on a dance
when you ask God your questions since I
still have yet to film that video that's
it I'll see you guys soon
and I'm Charles II guys in New York or
some of you who knows I'll see you later
a by E